despite the difficulties of the pandemic
some local businesses have been able to
expand to growing areas of the valley
reporter kate houston joins us live in
the newsroom tonight after speaking to
the owner of number one boba tea
about their plans to open a store up in
the northwest valley
kate yes sasha number one boba tea has
been a mainstay in las vegas for more
than 20 years
the family run business has branched out
to eight different locations
with plans to expand even further
meaning not many people actually know
bulba
so we had to educate customers
and explain what boba is amy zhang
warthan started running the original
number one boba tea
chinatown location more than 15 years
ago she says it's taken years of
outreach to expand her business which
offers boba a tea based drink
often mixed with milk or fruit for
flavor with chewy tapioca pearls at the
bottom
very soon we hear customers say
why don't you come to my side of town so
that's how we started expanding
and thinking oh customers actually want
this bova in their neighborhood
in early march a new spot will open in
the northwest valley near durango and
centennial parkway
the team decided to open this location
due to the lack of boba options in the
area and how quickly the northwest is
growing
daniel warthan amy's stepson and owner
of the aliante location
says they were able to move forward with
their plans during the pandemic because
of the loyalty from the community
because of the customers we've been able
to move into other areas of the valley
and serve all the people and know that
we'll be confident that people will come
after their success in the las vegas
valley this local business will be
heading out of state for the first time
a location will open outside of austin
texas in early summer
zhang worthen says there's some interest
from other states as well
and even overseas nothing solid at this
point but we are working on it it's
like popcorn it's heating up
yes it is centennial hills will be their
ninth location in the valley with
another spot opening up near the
lifeguard arena in henderson
zhang morthan hopes to have some of her
employees take over a location
to learn how to run a business and
develop some new skills